all right there was a post on reddit the
other day called why is eggs so strong
and i gotta say it piqued my interest we
all know that eggs are renowned for
their weight to strength ratio as in how
much weight an egg can hold in
proportion to its own weight but how
much weight could a human hold if they
were as strong as an egg now in order to
figure this out obviously we must first
determine how much weight an egg can
hold
i've got four caps here we have to kind
of have an even plane so the caps what
they do is level it out and hit the
right pressure points we're starting
small one with a single egg for those of
you who don't use the imperial system of
weights 16 ounces is of one pound and if
you need to remember that a pint is a
pound the world around a limited edition
actually i don't know if this is limited
edition
a classic corridor digital coffee mug
it weighs 11.8 ounces 11 11 ounces
right now no problem no problem
all right egg you're doing pretty good
egg can it hold three pounds three
pounds you gotta balance it just right
that's the thing about eggs though you
can't tell there's no give
oh there you go it's still up dude
that's three pounds
let's see if we can hold an mp7 this is
the heaviest item so far
[Music]
oh god
dude holy cow
holy crap we're still on a single egg
here
that's a lot
what's going on
andrew lehman indiana
pennsylvania what what
indiana
pennsylvania indiana is apparently a
town in pennsylvania andrew said
something over what is it
it is a cool spaceman picture tell me
andrew's a weird artist this is a print
of a collage i made hope you like it
it'll be like goats keep making great
stuff
sorry andrew
it's just drew oh there yet whoa
the post office decided that this
envelope needs to be crushed a couple
times yeah they've made it vintage
that's cool look at the like the
eyeballs drew drew is a true artist the
opposite of mainstream i love it did you
make that i drew it
go dot png and then use like paste paste
paste leave a comment of uh what this
sound would make in in the comments
below
i wanna i wanna know if it can hold this
and then from there we can go back down
to see where what it can actually hold a
red camera with brain side handle lens
monitor and battery this is the real
test right here you guys if you could
hold a red cam
what
13 pounds
we're bouncing around on one end i need
to lift this just so i see that you
gotcha
that is just an egg
one egg with two caps only an egg
what
i honestly i did not think that it would
hold this right here you can see it
perfectly
what these are 20 pounds each okay we're
gonna need to put this on top because
the next thing we're going to test are
sandbags
they're 20 pounds each which means that
a single one obviously is heavier than
the red can it hold two can it hold one
i don't know we're about to find out
all right here's what happened a really
good friend devin graham devin
supertramp if you don't know who he is
you should send us one of his world
famous signature devin graham glidecams
we've been waiting a week to open it
check it out with us now the box was
sitting right here and it's gone did you
hide it did you hide it
did you hide it oh there it is
i've been waiting for this so bad i'm
really amped about this you know why
we've had ronins we've had gimbal
systems but you know what i love about
this system sun it's all just a system
of weights and counterweights no battery
required you can go from glidecam status
to held by just grabbing the pole in an
instant i really want to play around
with this i'm super excited about it
wait let me see
oh devon's name's on that too yeah it's
on the box he signed it right here he
signed the bank dude yeah i can see he
signed that this is his he
dude what a nice swell dude yeah he
signed it how classy comes in a little
case all right here we go uh i suppose i
should read the instructions i'm running
first place hey don't footage
all right extendable base
[Music]
23 pounds
oh this is going to [ __ ] squirt egg
juice all over me you're all in your
face oh you're going to squirt egg juice
oh there it goes
egg
egg number two
okay we know 23 pounds is too much so
let's go back to a lighter weight and
add incrementally until we find the
exact breaking point
16 pounds will it hold
i think it's gonna
oh no problem
no problem sixteen foot
just down well it's still held
not even a problem all right 16 and 23
where it broke we're getting closer
let's see if we had another two pound
battery how it holds 18 pounds yeah
that'll bring us to 18 pounds actually
to bring us to 18 pounds 10 ounces and
we know it breaks at 23. we know we're
getting close
off camera time
pretty solid
hands off hands are off
okay dude that's 18 pounds 18 pounds 10
ounces that's almost 19 pounds is a lot
of weight i think we'll hit the breaking
point if we add this sigma lens let's go
see how much it weighs
yeah there you go so adds what it adds
two pounds so 15 pounds 15 ounces we are
nearly at max weight with a battery and
a pancake will be at pretty much 20
pounds exactly maybe 20 and a half
i don't think it's going to hold this
let's find out
[Music]
now let's find the balance
we could take out this yeah i think
let's try it without the battery okay
yeah okay in between the window we know
where it knows we can hold and it
working yeah
how's it going dude
it's hypnotically smooth
it's so heavy
check this out dude check out this
butter
[Music]
all right final test guys we're right in
the sweet spot right now this is 19
pounds 10 ounces that's only 6 ounces
short of 20 pounds where we know it
breaks
that i think that was the sliding i
think it's safe to assume that a single
egg will hold 19 pounds of weight which
far exceeds the weight of an egg let's
go back let's figure out exactly what
that is by proportion to a human being
i've done the math it's kind of
really ridiculous here's how i do this
an average egg we estimate holds about
19 pounds of weight that's 8.62
kilograms the average egg weighs 2
ounces so that's a ratio of
152 to 1. pretty ridiculous now it's
kind of subjective in terms of how much
weight a human can hold but i did some
digging the greatest weight ever
documented to have been lifted was in
the 1950s by this american guy he
supposedly backlifted
6
270 pounds now who knows if that's even
true or not that doesn't even matter
because the average human weight is 137
pounds and a human by the most liberal
of estimates can only hold 45 to one so
what does that mean in terms of actual
weight
it means that a human being would be
able to hold 20
824 pounds that would be like holding up
two
elephants as you can see i've
illustrated this with my very detailed
dry erase drawing right here oh here's
another crazy fact all right yeah
13
of the weight of an entire egg
is its shell meaning
that
only 13 of the weight is doing all of
that lifting and i haven't even included
that in this map